هذا مشهد لمحمد سعد في نوبه غضب كواليس
تصوير مسلسل الجديد
وانتشر هذا الفيديو وهو يطلق بعد عبارات
سباب وايضا كانه طاقم العمل بالتقصير
بمسلسل اكسيلونس شو اللي صار يا استاذ
طارق يعني لماذا
يدفع شباك بهذا الحجم
انا حزين على فنان كبير وموهبه كبيره جدا
ياما اتكلمت عن موهبته اللي هو محمد سعد
لكن في السنوات العشر الاخيره لم يكن في
الاثنى عشر الاخيره لم يستطع محمد سعد
الحفاظ على المكاسب الحقها على مستوى
الجمهور
واعماله الاخيره فعلا
سواء كانت في التليفزيون او في السينما
اثبتت ان الجمهور بدا يعني سحب عنه
المشكله مش في موهبه محمد سعد المشكله انه
محمد سعد فقد روح المغامره بياخد من الدرج
او بالخزين ويعيد تقديمه مره يسخنه يعني
بيسموها مثلا في مصر يقول لك يامر رغيف
العيش يامروا يعني يسخنه كده فهو يجي يامر
البضاعه الدراميه القديمه او الشخصيه
القديمه ويقدمها هنا الفنان بيفقد روح
المغامره بيفقد في نفس اللحظه روح الابداع
ثوره محمد سعد
اللي سببها الاخفاق الرقمي اللي عمله
المسلسل انه مشاهدته ضئيله متابعته ضئيله
لكن هو لو فكر شويه هيكتشف ان في مشاكل في
الكتابه هو مسؤول عنها ايضا لانها وافق
على النص في مشاكل في الاخراج في مشاكل
عند محمد سعد في اختياره للشخصيه نفسها
لانه سبق ان هو قدمها يعني في كركر سبق
تقديم الشخصيه دي فهو مش قادر يهرب بره
مضيء لا محمد سعد موهبه لكن عليه ان يتحرر
من الماضي وانا حزين حزين جدا انه يعني
بالمقطع اللي احنا سمعناه وتقريبا العالم
العربي كله سمعوا في تجاوزات في تجاوزات
حتى اضطر فريق العمل او المخرج انه يقول
لا ما كانش موجهه لنا يعني يا استاذ طارق
غلطه الشاطر بالف